the DeLorean dmc-12 drove its way into
movie history in Back to the Future but
there's a lot about the iconic car that
you may not know from its crammed
interior to its souped-up engine this is
the history of everyone's favorite
two-door time machine the true story
behind the DeLorean DMC 12 is a wild one
and The Man Behind the iconic car is a
huge part of it John DeLorean was the
youngest division head in General Motors
history responsible for the GTO and the
firebird when he was head engineer at
Pontiac after the success of the GTO
delorean's personality and lifestyle
changed and tensions between him and
other GM Executives grew after leaving
GM at the Maverick engineer founded the
DeLorean Motor Company in 1975. one
thing to disrupt the automotive industry
with a sports car that was safe
sustainable and fuel efficient despite
its futuristic look and early interest
though the dmc-12 wasn't everything the
laureena promised and the new motor
company experience funding issues before
the factory in Northern Ireland began
production georgetto jujaro the lauded
Automotive designer base of DMC 12 on
his design for the one-up concept car
called The Voice top hero gujaro also
designed the Lotus Esprit which became
James Bond's underwater car in 1977's
the spy who loved me suggesting that the
DeLorean was destined for the Silver
Screen in October of 1982 John DeLorean
was arrested for drug trafficking after
meeting with agents in an undercover
sting operation the Laurier must charge
his conspiracy to distribute 55 pounds
of cocaine in what most believed was a
desperate attempt to raise funds to save
his fledgling Motor Company weeks after
Deloreans arrested the lawyer Motor
Company declared bankruptcy in 1984
DeLorean was acquitted by a jury when
they ruled the Hoffman and the FBI had
entrapped the automotive innovator but
the damage had been done to both his
company and his public standing
delorean's financial and legal troubles
continued after DMC went Belly Up
DeLorean was accused of misappropriating
funds and was sued by investors I have
no hostility you know no desire for
Revenge I'm not mad at anybody I just
want to get on with my the British
government also investigated DeLorean
who faced trials for fraud and
embezzlement civil suits settled in the
decades following the dissolution of his
company drove the lawyer into bankruptcy
and he was forced to sell his New Jersey
estate to Donald Trump in 2000. John
DeLorean died in 2005 after suffering a
stroke he was 80 years old the time
machine for the Back to the Future
Trilogy wasn't always intended to be the
iconic DeLorean DMC 12. in an early
iteration of the script the time machine
was a refrigerator that Doug Brown
carted around on the back of a pickup
director and co-writer Robert zemakis
told the Santa Barbara Film Festival we
actually had thoughts of putting a time
machine in a refrigerator at one point
but we worried that kids would start
locking themselves in refrigerators Not
only was the time machine originally
much colder but an early version of The
Back to the Future script almost note
the fridge 25 years before everyone's
favorite archaeologist did so in Indiana
Jones on the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull in an early version of the scripts
the fridge is taken to a nuclear test
site where a harness says the power of
the nuclear Blaster sent Marty McFly
Back to 1985. after being told that the
production needed to cut the budget by
one million dollars so Mecca is a writer
producer Bob Gale eventually realized
that a lightning strike supplying 1.21
gigawatts of the flux capacitor was a
much more elegant solution thus Back to
the Future was saved from the ridicule
Indiana Jones experienced after the
fourth film in his franchise depicted a
lead-lined fridge being used to survive
an atomic blast after Robert zamacchus
and Bob Gale decided that Doug Brown's
time travel device should be mobile
zemekis had an epiphany Gail told Box
Office Mojo sobekus came up with this
idea that it would be cool to use a
DeLorean because it could be mistaken
for a flying saucer the way I see it if
you're gonna build a time machine into a
car why not do some style the futuristic
look at the DeLorean was an important
reason for the decision so Mac has told
the Hollywood Foreign Press Association
we chose the DeLorean basically because
it was the only car that existed that
had Gull Wing doors and would look kind
of like a spaceship to someone in the
50s when Marty crashes into a barn and
Mr Peabody's Farm after arriving in 1955
Piedmont his son is quick to make the
connection between the dmt12 and the
spaceship showing his family the cover
of the comic book he was reading about
aliens from outer space after Robert
zamacchus and Bob Gale decided that that
time machine should be a car automotive
Giants courted the studio Ford
reportedly offered the studio 75 000 if
they use the Mustang in Back to the
Future this wasn't an unreasonable
request considering how the liberal use
of product placement helps display the
time periods Marty and duck visit during
the three films still Gail was quick to
shoot the offer down by saying Doug
Brown doesn't drive a Mustang
the studio handled much of the movie's
product placement without input from
zemecus and Gail but the co-creators of
Back to the Future had their hearts set
on the DeLorean they made a licensing
deal with John DeLorean in 1989 giving
Universal Studios merchandising and
commercial use of the cars designed for
five percent of the revenue Universal
Pictures use 60 mc-12s and one
fiberglass replica for the Back to the
Future Trilogy Robert zemekis and Bob
Gale gave their designers little
guidance but insisted that the machine
co-made as The Eccentric Doug Browner
constructed it in the privacy of his
garage our sister Von Cobb illustrator
Andy Probert and production designer
Larry Paul worked on renderings for the
time machine Mike chafe the vehicle
construction coordinator along with
special effects supervisor Kevin Pike
and his team gave multiple Deloreans a
makeover for the Back to the Future
Trilogy keeping the dmc-12s in Tip-Top
shape during production was a constant
struggle as the cars were quite fragile
and broke down often during filming
there were three cars modified for the
first film car a was a big star while
car B did stunt work and car c was used
for interior shots for the second and
third films more Deloreans joined the
fleet the fiberglass replica was used
for flying scenes and the b car was
modified to fit on the railroad tracks
for the third film finally Desert Car
number one and desert card number two
were used for the last movie in the
trilogy the Marty travels to the old
west to save Doug Brown during his time
running his company John DeLorean plans
to make a turbocharged version of the
dmc-12 he even had a contract of Legend
Industries at USB company that would
handle the conversion sadly his plans
for a turbocharged DMC 12 was scrubs
before the DeLorean Motor Company went
bankrupt as Legend Industries itself and
bankrupt while waiting for DmC to fix
their production and funding issues the
DMC 12 had 130 horsepower and
accelerated from zero to 60 miles per
hour in just over 10 seconds which
wasn't as good as its contemporary
competition in 1981 one of these
competitors was a Porsche 911 another
rare engine sports car that was lighter
and faster therefore Universal Studios
decided to replace the dmc-12's original
V6 engine with one from a Porsche
Instead This alteration essentially
created a supercharged version of the
dmc12 similar to what DeLorean planned
on offering in response to complaints
about the car's speed and power this is
regular online
fortunately no it requires something
with a little more kick plutonium the
original speedometer of the DMC 12 only
reached 85 miles per hour as a 1979
mandate signed into law by President
Jimmy Carter cut them at that number to
deter speeding the effects Department of
Back to the Future had to swap out of
the delorean's original speedometer with
one that reached to 95 miles per hour
they also added a digital one to the
dashboard for accuracy and dramatic
effect while this might seem like a
minor detail Doug Brown's the lawyer
must hit 88 miles an hour to enter the
past or future making the enhancement
absolutely necessary Virtua was 88 miles
per hour the number zemeckis and Gail
decided on there are some scientific
theories about rates of speed and
wormholes in the Back to the Future
universe but the truth is apparently
much more simple Gail reportedly told
comic book first of all we wanted it to
be a speed that somebody wouldn't
accidentally drive her the other thing
is it's easy to remember when this baby
hits 88 miles per hour
you're gonna see some serious
although Back to the Future secure the
DeLorean DMC 12 are placed in cinematic
history the filmmakers admitted it
wasn't always a Cooperative star Bob
Gale told Esquire as cool as it looks on
film it's by no means a performance car
it broke down a lot and little things on
the car would break during a scene and
would have to wait for the effects guys
to repair it the going doors on the DMC
12 ruined multiple takes drawing one
exceptionally chilly night while filming
the lightning strike scene the doors of
the DMC 12 are supposed to remain up
thanks to gas-filled cylinders but the
doors wouldn't stay open in The Frigid
conditions the crew resorted to warming
the cylinders with hair dryers between
takes to keep the doors open while
filming although Michael J fox and
Christopher Lloyd became close friends
over the years Fox never expressed kind
words about his Automotive co-star Fox
joked to notice I wish I had a video a
gag reel of how many times I was hit by
that freaking door the DeLorean door
take after take it would go whack
despite not enjoying working with the
DMC 12 Fox must have recognized they
made a dynamic duo on screen one of the
DMC 12's used him back to the future
known as the Seeker was cut apart in
order to film interior shots of the time
machine the cabin of a DeLorean
especially with all the stylistic
modifications was simply too crammed for
a 35 millimeter panaflex camera and an
actor to fit inside that's why the
scenes filmed in the sea car was shot on
the back lot of Universal Studios and
the background outside the cabin of the
DMC 12 was projected the C car ended up
being used for internal shots in all
three films Michael J fox reportedly
hated working with DeLorean while
filming the Sci-Fi Trilogy and the
crammed interior was a source of his
hatred he told nudist it was the worst
thing to drive it had two gears and I
slammed the gears and my hand would
smash into the funk's capacitor my hands
would be bleeding my head would be
bleeding I had to clean it off to get to
the family tie set let's land animal
his car parties in a 46 Ford
wearing a DeLorean he ripped through us
like we were tin foil the hero car or
car a which was featured in most scenes
and Beauty shots from the Back to the
Future Trilogy was used by Universal
Pictures and Universal Studios for
promotional purposes for years the Back
to the Future theme park ride was filmed
with the acre but after years of use it
was left to the elements in the park and
began to deteriorate fans took pieces of
the car home and it was in sorry shape
the hero car was given a museum quality
restoration by Terry matalis and Joe
Walser who had already made a couple of
replicas before convincing Universal to
allow a team to take on the restoration
the 20-person team spent over a year
restoring the DeLorean to its pristine
film star condition and after the
restoration was completed in 2013 the
hero car was displayed at the universal
experience in 2016 the hero car was
loaned to Peterson Automotive Museum in
Los Angeles and has been on display
there ever since in 2021 the hero car
became the 29th car added to the
National Historic vehicle register
because of its cultural significance the
fiberglass replica that was used for the
flying scenes in the sequel was put on
display at Universal Studios but was
destroyed years later the beaker
nicknames the wreckage car did all the
stunts almost destroyed by a train after
it was retrofitted with train wheels for
the third film part of the car were used
in replicas and some panels were hung
from the ceiling of Planet Hollywood in
Hawaii the car later became part of a
private collection owned by father son
Duo Bill and Patrick Shea many parts
from the sea car which had already been
cut apart were used to build a replica
for Universal Studios in Japan a private
company ultimately purchased this
replica and they displayed at their
entrance the Oxnard Car which was used
during filming of Back to the Future
Part 3 in Oxnard California most
displayed at Universal Studios Florida
before being put in storage where it's
still languishes two desert cars were
also used while filming the third movie
in Monument Valley one was restored for
a private collection and the other was
initially used for parts what remained
was later combined with parts from the
sea car to make the replica for display
in Japan